simple économique savoureux réconfortant
la liste est longue quand vient le temps
de parler de braisé qui soit de viande
ou végétarien
alors voilà Johan c'est ça le bœuf
braisé c'est magnifique votre petite
sauce
c'est vraiment bon je me suis invité
chez Jean-Paul grappe réputé chef
enseignant au menu un repas goûteux mais
pas coûteux le Brésil
en ce moment avec le problème qu'on
connaît là faut essayer de cuisiner des
choses qui coûtent moins cher c'est
quelle partie ça c'est du plat de côte
c'est des Ribes en fin de compte ça
revient à 4 dollars 50 le morceau pour
deux personnes
dans chaque animal il y a des pièces qui
sont faites pour être cuites à basse
température ou braisé faut jamais jamais
faire de braiser avec des parties de
viande noble si vous prenez de
l'entrecôte c'est pas bon parce que ça
va être sec à l'idée d'un Brésil c'est
que le gras qui est à l'intérieur de
cette partie viande la comme ici il y en
a aussi il y en a ici du gras voyez il y
en a ici c'est qu'à la cuisson ça va
nourrir la viande si j'ai pas de boucher
que je vais à l'épicerie je choisis quoi
la palette je fais partie de l'épaule
j'arrête jamais ça fait un excellent
Brésil c'est beau c'est magnifique
du siècle dernier ça c'est une brésière
quand on fait un Brésil faut que ça soit
fait normalement dans une braisière à
défaut d'avoir une telle braisière le
chef recommande une cocotte en fonte
émaillée ou encore de faire une
braisière à partir d'une simple
casserole je mets un papier aluminium
l'idée c'est que il faut pas que la
vapeur à la cuisson sorte je suis pas
très bon un dessin vous m'excuserez mais
c'est ça le principe à ce qui se passe
vous voyez la vapeur elle monte ici hop
elle veut sortir là mais le couvercle il
est là là elle coin il est coincé il
peut pas sortir alors est-ce qu'elle
fait elle revient sur le centre et à
force les gouttelettes s'accumulent pour
elle retombe elle retombe sur la viande
et ça la nourrit
passons maintenant de la théorie à la
pratique alors là la viande elle a bien
faire colorée mais vous avez tout
simplement faire venir votre viande
c'est ça que j'ai fait revenir la viande
avec un petit peu d'huile le moins
possible et maintenant on va mettre les
ingrédients pour la cuisson
on va mettre les éléments aromatiques le
temps le laurier les baies de genièvres
les plus girofle qu'on aime en fin de
compte de l'ail en entoure ça avec des
légumes que l'on aime ça peut être du
céleri ça peut être du poireau ça peut
être des carottes ça peut être des
tabags et je vais faire le ce qu'on
appelle un court-moulement ne reste qu'à
ajouter du liquide ici un fond préparé
avec des autres boeuf qui ont mijoté
dans l'eau avec des aromates deux heures
de cuisson on passe au Thémis et le tour
est joué vous voyez pas plus que ça
c'est à peine pour avoir un fond liquide
quand on dit un braisé c'est à
court-moulement c'est qu'il faut pas que
ça soit recouvert d'immersion parce
qu'on sait qu'il faut pas que la vapeur
sorte et ça je vais mettre ça dans le
four à 325 pendant deux heures deux
heures et quart
il est aussi possible d'utiliser la
cuisson lente avec des protéines
végétales
Évelyne on parle de braisé puis dans
votre nouveau livre vous nous préparez
deux recettes de mijoter c'est la même
chose mais c'est pas la même chose parce
que clairement on travaille pas avec la
viande donc quand on fait briser on fait
briser surtout avec la viande on
pourrait travailler un petit peu de
cette façon là avec notre tempe on le
fait saisir on commence comme si on
allait Brésil viande exactement donc
dans l'huile avec de l'oignon qu'on fait
saisir on vient vraiment sortir encore
plus de saveurs c'est un ingrédient qui
humanit à la base donc on vient vraiment
rehausser le tout en faisant ça comme ça
j'ai vraiment voulu qu'on ait retrouvé
les mêmes saveurs que dans les mijotés
ou des braisés à la viande que nos mains
nous faisaient à la maison super
réconfortant donc avec le mijoté de
tempé de patates de carottes de panais
avec du vin rouge aussi dans une sauce
épaisse onctueuse donc on retrouve
vraiment les saveurs qu'on connaît avec
les protéines végétales Yvelines
préfèrent travailler sur la cuisinière
qu'on amène ça à ébullition puis une
fois que ça bout on ajoute le couvercle
et on fait cuire ça pendant 2h30
la gourgane et l'orge sont les vedettes
de la deuxième création toujours en
cuisson lente
j'avais envie qu'on fasse changement de
la soupe à la gourgane qu'on incline
dans un mijoté c'est vraiment
légumineuse à découvrir peu de gens la
cuisine à la maison elle se trouve
facilement aussi en conserve à
l'épicerie toute l'année des fois on la
trouve fraîche qu'on est chanceux tout
dépendant de la région où on est mais je
l'ai vraiment la mettre de l'avant
qu'elle est très délicate au niveau des
saveurs donc accompagné avec des herbes
fraîches un petit peu à l'italienne de
l'orge des tomates
[Musique]
comment tu trouves ça je trouve ça très
bon c'est drôle parce que c'est vraiment
un mariage entre la soupe oui à la
gourgane la soupe alors il y a pas de
bœuf rien mais c'est aussi savoureux
c'est très très bon
les légumes on le goût d'un bon Brésil
j'ai vraiment voulu y aller avec des
classiques qu'on a dans nos mijotés
réconfortant
réconfortant qu'on se sentent peu des
paysans non plus très réussi merci
beaucoup Evelyne
[Musique]